welcome back to Greg's animal friends or
Gaff the segment where each guest shares
a clip of a critter you gotta see to
believe uh we're doing this now you know
because 10 o'clock people love pets
animals and stuff get the young demo
into animals right cat you go first why
thank you you're welcome you have a
video of an elephant being cute uh-huh
you'll see so let's look at the little
baby elephant chasing birds and clearly
like it's not going to work but all the
older elephants are like just let them
let them figure it out who cares they
don't look hold on here it comes here it
comes oh
and then he's like oh hey look I kind of
messed that up
I think that's really just a beautiful
moment and it proves that elephant kids
are just as dumb as human ones yeah
elephant kids that's pretty funny
I just thought of a kid that looks like
an elephant yeah that's not very nice is
it Kennedy Kennedy yes we should make
fun of children who look like elephants
you go next I think the fact that we
don't make fun of anyone anymore is why
Society is crumbling before our very
eyes Greg well thank you there are two
animals in this world that look cute but
you can't trust them hippopotamuses or
hippopotami and squirrels
here's a cute video of a squirrel
playing with a woman's hair she's a
woman who's so lonely she's given up on
life and she's given up on cats and
she's started raising rodents and the
only uh interaction and intimacy she has
is when this girl plays with her hair
and she reaches the height of her
exactly right her oh
and that's what's in she's probably
getting rabies at the same time so she
won't be with us much longer but it was
fun while it lasted Greg it's beautiful
it's very beautiful it's sad and it's
beautiful the squirrel has no idea what
he's being used for a guy and that's
really the sad part and squirrel
trafficking
you are queer
[Applause]
for those for those who just tuned in
that's a callback
the previous segment saving your job my
friend oh there you have it so cat I see
your elephant video and I raise you an
elephant video this is also a baby
elephant 10 months old named Brazos and
he is blowing bubbles and it is the
cutest thing I've seen in the last 30
seconds and he is just delighted with
this entire situation and that's all
I've got how
how is he blowing bubbles where's it
coming from
the trunk
blowing the bubbles there's a bubble
machine in the previous frame I prefer
to think that he's I'm fact checking you
blowing bubbles
I think it's a Man in the Yellow Hat
that's actually uh those are unicorn
farts and those will power our Teslas in
the near future
well you know what happened the last
time I blew bubbles
uh he quit the circus
[Laughter]
[Applause]
a lot you want to say it this time
nope nope
all right Tyrus close it out
oh they're not watching anymore after
that one
seeing how I was on a plane I'm not sure
which clip got so if I can get a hint is
it my good buddies yes awesome so uh my
good buddy of Godfather Exotics has just
hatched a first these are some of the
rarest strands of ball python breeds
ever they're some of the craziest color
and this the there's a cinnamon pied
ball and there and there's a banana
cinnamon pied ball and there's a super
cinnamon pied ball and then finally he
came up with one that has yet to be seen
uh and it is let me scroll down and make
sure I get the name right it is a
scaleless
pinstripe
piedball and it's amazing
so when you breed snakes you try to get
exotic different cool colors and this
guy has hit the jackpot and he had
six unique babies that you will not see
and it's like a fingerprint no other
ones are the same so it's pretty cool I
think they're called snakes of color
Tyrus
that's why Cuomo doesn't like you
little person
[Laughter]
somebody make me a shirt TLP
#cuomo
l-o-l-l-m-f-a-o that's what the kids do
all right up next are you okay I had I
didn't I didn't get home last night
until very late and and uh yeah I'm
having problems you're drooling I'm not
drooling how was bubbles
laughs
uh he dropped the S it goes by Buble
go behind the scenes hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else